all right joining us now for reaction is
the aforementioned Carter Paige a former
Trump campaign advisor whom the FBI
surveilled as well as Michael Caputo a
former Trump campaign aide who has been
interviewed by special counsel Robert
Muller's team gentlemen it's great to
have you both on tonight thank you so
much for joining us
Carter let's start with you you you had
a lot of contact with this informant hey
whatever we want to call him informant
spy mole and I want to read one of the
emails that he sent to you that was
released by I think it was Daily Caller
got this initially dear Carter I thought
I'd write as the summer wears on to ask
how you are and what your plans are at
this point it seems attention has
shifted a bit from the collusion
investigation to the Contra tantrum so
of course you misspelled it within the
White House and how or if mr.
scaramouche II will be accommodated
there I must assume this gives you some
relief we're here in Virginia etc etc be
in touch when you have the time would be
great to catch up
we're not mentioning the informants name
but Carter what did you first meet this
informant that we now know as an
informant and just briefly tell us about
that exchange well you know again I
similar to you in terms of being
cautious about identity I have also I
never knew anything about the person I
was speaking with who's a university
professor at Cambridge and in the UK at
the time back I was invited to
participate in a conference in July of
2016 and everything seemed totally
normal so and frankly I've been falsely
accused myself and I you know we'll see
what happens in terms of you know as
further details come out but based on
everything I've seen thus far you know I
I still we still don't have any
information so there's been a lot of it
yeah we know we know he was paid a
million dollars over five years pretty
good money as a consultant or researcher
but yeah you're right well we shall see
but question Carter before we go on to
Michael
who started the conversation how did the
date begin sorry but you know did he
approach you did he mention Russia
collusion first how did it go you know
we had it was a multi-day conference and
there were scholars and people from
government both from the United I know
but I know but stay focused with
McCarter did he approach you first did
you approach him how did you first start
speaking I see I don't even recall we
were we spent a couple days together and
you know there's days together you know
it's a long event over several days and
right but there were a lot of Scot what
I'm saying is there a lot of scholars
there and you know you you have to know
the process of grooming someone when
someone when someone is an informant
they don't just go up to someone say hey
I want to plant information on you or
find out what you have you try to win
someone's trust over there that's how it
goes I never felt groomed so if he's a
if he's good at doing that then perhaps
that's part of the game you don't know
to it standing here right you don't know
who mentioned the Russia collusion issue
first I can't even remember you know I
think Russia was in the news and I think
you know a lot of politics sort of
revolves around various news events and
so you know these various stories came
up you know again we stayed in touch for
for over a year and looking back I'm
sorry to interrupt but looking boy
limited-time looking back on it does
anything seem odd or just you know how
you know something like oh maybe that
was a little odd or any other contacts
you had with any other people that
seemed now in retrospect given what we
know now odd out of the ordinary or
maybe in many in some way improper well
you know I tend to give people the
benefit of doubt and I you know we'll
see maybe they this individual who we're
talking about might have been a little
bit nicer than he might then I might
otherwise have expected although you
know he was we were talking about all
the abuses that were happening with this
dodgy dossier which was first debuted in
September 2016
as a way of damaging the Trump campaign
and basically destroying myself and so
you know and he always seemed very
sympathetic about that so again you know
we'll see I like to give people that
benefit out people that know him in
Washington in senior circles that I've
spoken with afterwards say you know you
seem like a pretty decent guy so I you
know I give that would be the perfect
that would be the perfect person to use
for for maybe I'm just cynical been
around Washington too long Carter you
well if only they gave you the benefit
of the doubt like you're giving other
people who benefit out Michael let's go
to you you've been through the meat
grinder at the Muller Muller
investigation he has the legal eagles
all these really highly skilled
interviewers prosecutors on his side
many of them not all of them but many of
them have I believe have a built-in
animus against Donald Trump you are very
angry that you've been dragged into this
as a former associate of Roger stone you
also did some work for the Trump
campaign tell us what you think you just
heard what Carter said about this you
know reported informant for the FBI well
I think Carter's been through more of a
meat grinder than I have and he's
handled it as a gentleman in fact when I
first heard about this stuff I think in
2016 2017 about Carter I wasn't very
kind in my criticism and I think you
know it looks like they were really
abusing Carter I think they were really
treating him poorly and I think a lot of
us Oh Carter an apology because we
didn't wait to hear the truth at the end
and now we're finding out that his
country was really failing him for
months and months and even years I'm
angry I'm surprised that Carter's not
he's a greater man that I I think but
I'll tell you this is really sick and
twisted stuff and like Carter said this
gentleman who's who shall not be named
has a reputation of being very
pro-american very patriotic and if in
fact you know he was brought into this
under false circumstances or false
pretenses as well he did find the guy
that a deep state would target yeah well
a dot I mean the dossier was the basis
for getting this FISA warrant I don't
care what these people say it was all a
big lie without
this dossier Carter page would not have
been surveilled in the fall of 2016 that
would not have happened that's why they
were running to that Russian oligarch
Oleg Deripaska to try to get him
involved he's like I don't even like
Paul mana for if this is ridiculous
though they were doing everything they
could they're working the page angle
they probably were working this
informant angle in and they brought you
in Michael which we'll get to in a
moment but I want to play for you what
Sally Yates the acting Attorney General
at the very beginning of the Trump
administration she's the one partly
responsible for interviewing Michael
Flynn at the beginning what she said
today on Morning Joe let's watch I think
what we're seeing here is the president
has just taken his all-out assault on
the rule of law to a new level and this
time he is ordering up an investigation
of the investigators who are examining
his own campaign you know that's really
shocking rod Rosenstein is is trying to
strike a balance here between defusing
this situation but also protecting the
rule of law and the institutional
integrity of the department Carter page
as I pointed out in the opening angle
the government under the Obama
administration had surveilled people and
lied about it and whether it was clapper
whether it was the the FBI under under
holder surveilling journalists they have
a history of having a problem telling
the truth on surveillance so for Sally
Yates to run out there and say oh well
that's Donald Trump's attacking the rule
of law come on your reaction well you
know just going to Michael's point about
you know things they did to me President
Trump during the campaign would often
say this is not about me this is about
us and I think of all of the terrible
things that happened to so many people
like Michael like you know some of the
other people who are involved allegedly
by with this informant I actually you
know spoke very positively my got a
positive impression about this informant
and I you know a couple of people I
mentioned him to in the campaign you
know I was a pretty positive endorsement
so I just I hope and pray that you know
all these allegations turn out to be
false and part of why I'm somewhat open
about
my communications with him is that it'll
it'll lead to some some truth finally
from the Department of Justice I've been
asking for you know DOJ to own up to
these things and it's funny the
defamation suit I have against a top
media organization and DOJ the media
organization is actually much more
honest than the false pleadings by the
DOJ so far hopefully they get out we got
to play this James clapper for Michael
he's he's basically just justifying the
use of any type of informant let's watch
the focus here and as it was with the
intelligence community is not on the
campaign per se but what the Russians
were doing to try to to instantiate
themselves in the campaign or to
influence or leverage it so if there was
someone that was observing that sort of
thing well that's a good thing because
the Russians pose a threat to the to arm
the very basis of our political system
Michael so you see a pattern here former
Obama administration officials
justifying spying on surveilling
whatever you want to call it putting a
mole in on a opposing campaign and a
hotly contested election here final
final thought that's right you've you've
spent time in Russia Carter and I both
have in Russia they call this this
Salovey key the national security
leadership that secretly spies on the
entire citizenry of Russia and here we
are in the United States with our own
Salovey key underneath president obama
let me tell you something that i know
for a fact the this informant this
person that they planted tried to plant
into the campaign and even into the
administration if you believe Axios he's
not the only person that came at the
campaign and the FBI is not the only
obama agency that came with the campaign
i know because they came at me and I'm
looking for clearance to my attorney
to reveal this to the public this is
just the beginning and I'll tell you
when we finally find out the truth about
this director clapper and the rest of
them are going to be wearing some orange
suits Michael Caputo and Carter Paige I
hope we get to the bottom of this
sooner than a lot of people were
predicting because the American people
deserve to know who is behind this who
authorized it and how high up the ladder
it went thank you both for joining
thanks all right